Hey guys, it's Ryan. In this video, we're going to continue to talk about oral pathology.
And this time we're going to move from benign connective tissue tumors to malignant connective
tissue tumors. And most of these are a malignant conversion of the previous lesions we just
talked about. So you may recognize a lot of similar sounding names. But with the addition
of sarcoma at the end. So if you remember back to when we talked about malignant mucosal
lesions, we were talking about carcinomas, because they're epithelial in origin. And
now that we're deeper in talking about some mucosa, we're going to use the root sarcoma
at the end of each of these lesions. So first, we have fibrosarcoma. And this is the malignant
proliferation of fibroblasts. So you'll notice that a lot of these connective tissue tumors,
or lumps and bumps as I call them, look kind of similar just on a spectrum of severity,
some being smaller and some being larger. So I'm not going to include pictures for all
these lesions for that reason. But the most important thing to know for each of these malignant
tissue tumors is the cell that's involved in the neoplasm in terms of an exam like the
part two boards. Next, we have neurofibrosarcoma, which is also known as a malignant peripheral
nerve sheath tumor. And this is a malignant proliferation of Schwann cells. So fibrosarcoma,
we had fibroblasts, and now we have Schwann cells. Next, we have Kaposi's sarcoma, which
is a malignant proliferation of endothelial cells. And endothelium is what lines the inside
of various organs, including the blood and lymphatic vessels. And it's caused by human
herpes virus eight, and most commonly seen as a complication of AIDS. And I'm going
to go back on my word. And this one, I do have a picture because unlike the other ones
we're going to talk about in the video, this has a very characteristic and unique appearance
clinically. So it's this deep purple lesion. Here we have it on the inside of the hard
palate. And anything purple is usually nine times out of ten associated with Kaposi's
sarcoma. It's just a very characteristic color. And often test makers like to make that link.
And lastly, we have three more malignant connective tissue tumors that we want to cover. And
the first is lio myosarcoma, which if we're picking apart the roots here is a malignancy
of smooth muscle cells. We have rhabdo myosarcoma, submalignancy of skeletal muscle cells. And
lastly, we have a malignancy of fat cells. And here's a slide from my previous video
on benign connective tissue tumors. And you might notice how similar these names are.
And they have the exact same cell of origin. So really, you just have to memorize the benign
ones and you'll have the malignant ones memorized then too. So that's a nice little twist to
have in terms of studying for these tumors. So that's actually all for this video guys.
Thanks again for watching. If you like this video, please leave a like on the video and
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already for more oral pathology and other things dentistry.
Thanks again for watching guys, and I'll see you all in the next video.